[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen den Sport hat Norbert
Lehmann für sie ein schön guten Abend
auch von mir unsere großen Themen heute
Urteil zur
Parteienfinanzierung
verfassungsfeindlichen Parteien wie der
rechtsextrem NPD können staatliche
Gelder gestrichen
werden
schwerste Verluste für Israel seit
Kriegsbeginn bei Kämpfen im Gazastreifen
sterben an einem Tag 24
Soldaten und nur noch ein Sieg bis zum
Halbfinale die deutschen Handballer
schlagen Ungarn deutlich und können
weiter von einer Medaille
Träumen heute die Entscheidung vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht der früheren
NPD können als erwiesen
rechtsextremistischer und
verfassungsfeindlicher Partei die
staatlichen Gelder gestrichen werden
werden jetzt nimmt die Diskussion Fahrt
auf ob auch der AFD der Galan zugedreht
werden kann schauen wir auf den Fall NPD
nach Jahren der Erfolglosigkeit zog die
1964 gegründete NPD erstmals 2004 wieder
in einen Landtag ein und zwar in Sachsen
das spülte auch mehr staatliche Gelder
an die parteienkassen für jede Stimme
bei der Wahl und jedes Mitglied zwei
Verbotsverfahren scheiterten 2003 und 7
vor Gericht seit 2019 ist die NPD in
keinem Parlament mehr vertreten 2023
benannte sie sich um in die Heimat über
das karlsrohr Urteil berichtet Samuel
Kirsch die um die es heute geht ist
nicht nach karlsruh gekommen die
rechtsextreme NPD seit kurzem Heimat
boikottiert die Urteilsverkündung und so
schließt das Bundesverfassungsgericht
die Partei in Abwesenheit von der
staatlichen Parteienfinanzierung aus die
NPD habe zwar den Namen geändert nicht
aber ihre verfassungsfeindliche
Ausrichtung die Antragsgegnerin
missachtet nach wie vor die
freiheitliche demokratische Grundordnung
und ist nach ihren Zielen und dem
Verhalten ihrer Mitglieder und Anhänger
auf deren Beseitigung ausgerichtet statt
einer freiheitlichen Ordnung strebe die
NPD einen autoritären völkischen
Nationalstaat an das verstoße gegen das
Demokratieprinzip und die Menschenwürde
so das Gericht
deshalb ist die Antragsgegnerin für die
Dauer von 6 Jahren von der staatlichen
Finanzierung
auszuschließen 2017 hielt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht die NPD für zu
erfolglos um sie zu verbieten daraufhin
schufen Bundesrat und Bundestag neben
dem Parteiverbot die Möglichkeit
Parteien Fördergelder zu streichen heute
das erste Urteil dazu das Urteil der
Richterin und Richter hier am
Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe
ist glasklar für eine wehrhafte
Demokratie ist es zentral dass sie einer
verfassungsfeindlichen Partei den
geldhand zudrehen kann und zwar selbst
dann wenn diese verfassungsfeindliche
Partei so erfolglos ist dass sie nicht
verboten werden kann die NPD bekommt
wegen schlechter Wahlergebnisse schon
aktuell keine Gelder mehr zumindest für
6 Jahre bleibt das nun auch
so nach dem Urteil ging die frühere NPD
jetzt also die Frage was bedeutet das
für den Umgang mit der AFD der Kanzler
sieht das Urteil als best für den Kurs
dass man den Feinden der Freiheit nicht
viel Raum bieten darf es müsse nun auch
für andere Zusammenhänge geprüft werden
so Scholz über die Diskussion ob man
versuchen solle der AFD die staatliche
Förderung zu streichen berichtet
Christiane
hübscher bundesinnenministerin fäer
sieht in dem Urteil ein klares Signal
das über den Tag hinausreiche unser
demokratischer Rechtsstaat finanziert
keine Verfassungsfeinde und auch wenn
die Verfassungs rechtlichen Hürden für
künftige Verfahren hoch bleiben haben
wir jetzt ein weiteres Instrument um
gegen Verfassungsfeinde vorzugehen ein
Instrument mit dem man auch die AFD von
der Parteienfinanzierung ausschließen
könnte die Linke hält die
Gerichtsentscheidung für eine Blaupause
ich bin der Ansicht dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ganz klar
gesagt hat dass demokratiefeinde keinen
Anspruch auf staatliche Parteien
Finanzierung haben und damit sollte das
auch für die AFD gelten den Antrag für
ein solches Prüfverfahren könnten
Bundestag Bundesrat oder Bundesregierung
Stellen in der Ampelkoalition aber gibt
es Zurückhaltung wir werden das sicher
auch noch mal sehr sehr gründlich
betrachten
welche Rückschlüsse darauf zu ziehen
sind aber erstmal ist das Urteil nicht
einfach übertragbar aus der AFD gibt es
heute auch auf Nachfrage kein Statement
zum NPD Urteil aus der Union kommen
gemischte Signale für Markus Söder ist
das Urteil wegweisend man müsse dasselbe
nun auch für die AFD prüfen aberenn das
Verfassungsgericht uns jetzt die
Möglichkeit gibt unterhalb der Schwelle
des offiziellen Verbotsverfahrens eine
Möglichkeit zusetzen Grenzen zu ziehen
die Verfassungsfeinde in ihrem agieren
einzuschränken dann sollte man alles
prüfen ob das nicht geht und machb
zumindest kurzfristig wird das NPD
Urteil keine Auswirkungen für die AFD
haben denn selbst ein Prüfverfahren
würde Jahre
dauern und die möglichen Auswirkungen
des Urteils auf die AFD sind auch Thema
ZDF heute live im Gespräch mit einem
Verfassungsrechtler um 19:30 Uhr in
unserer App und auf den Social Media
Kanälen in Eitorf in nordreinwestfalen
haben afdptiker am Abend zu einem wie
Sie es nennen Bürgerdialog geladen auf
der Tagesordnung die sogenannte
Remigration ein Begriff den
rechtsextreme auch für die Vertreibung
von Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
aus Deutschland nutzen unter dem Motto
nie wieder ist jetzt finde zur sel Zeit
eine Gegendemonstration statt dazu
aufgerufen hatte ein breites Bündnis aus
Parteien Verbänden und
Vereinen und Vorort in eoff ist für uns
Heiko Rams Heiko wie groß ist der Unmut
und der Protest gegen die AFD
Veranstaltung ja die Menschen hier sind
richtig wütend ich befinde mich in
Eitorf das ist eine kleine Gemeinde im
rehein siegkreis etwa 20 000 Menschen
leben hier und von diesen 20000 Menschen
sich einige tausend hinter mir auf dem
Marktplatz die Polizei will sich noch
nicht festlegen was die genaue Zahl
eingeht und sie protestieren eben gegen
den AFD Bürgertreff etwa 100
Interessierte sind dort im Moment vor
Ort und informieren sich dort über das
Thema Remigration also die Vertreibung
von Menschen das macht die Menschen hier
wütend und deshalb scheint sich der
bundesweite Trend und Zulauf zu den
Demonstrationen gegen die AFD auch hier
in eitthorf fortzusetzen vielen Dank
Heiko
Rams im September wird in Sachsen ein
neuer Landtag gewählt und jetzt zeigt
der sogenannte sachsenmitor das
Vertrauen der Menschen in die Politik
ist weiter gesunken der Antisemitismus
hat zugenommen die Vorurteile gegenüber
Ausländern auch die regelmäßige Umfrage
zur Stimmung im Freistaat wird von der
Landesregierung in Auftrag gegeben über
die Ergebnisse Cornelia
schimens es sind widersprüchliche ergeb
die der aktuelle sachsenmitor spiegelt
auf der persönlichen Ebene sind die
allermeisten Menschen sehr zufrieden
weil ich selbständig bin genügend Kunden
hab eine nette Familie um mich rum
deswegen bin ich ganz glücklich ja wenn
man gesund ist ist man glücklich oder
viele jedoch haben große Sorgen ob die
Politik die gesellschaftlichen
Herausforderungen lösen kann das geht
aus der repräsentativen Studie mit der
Befragung von rund 2000 Sachsen hervor
zwar halten 83% der Befragten die
Demokratie für eine gute Regierungsform
allerdings sind 59% unzufrieden wie sie
in der Praxis umgesetzt wird der Frage
ob Deutschland in einem gefährlichen Maß
von Ausländern überfremdet ist stimmten
64% zu eine Steigerung um 24% Punkte zur
letzten
Erhebung wir Demokraten müssen beweisen
dass wir Herausforderungen Probleme die
Themen dieses Landes klären
wirtschaftlich steht Sachsen sehr gut da
milliardenschwere großansiedlungen in
der shipindustrie sorgen für gute Jobs
die Arbeitslosigkeit liegt mit 6,2% im
deutschen Mittelfeld doch offenbar lässt
sich daraus kein politisches Kapital
schlagen denn die Studie belegt auch es
findet ein rasanter Vertrauensverlust
statt in Parteien Institutionen und
Medien so ein verlorenes Vertrauen ist
ein wahnsinnig alarmierendes Signal für
eine Gesellschaft ne also wenn man da in
die Zukunft gemeinsam gehen möchte muss
man gucken dass man dieses Vertrauen
wieder aufbaut zumal Vertrauen keine
mathematische Gleichung ist sondern
etwas was man quasi miteinander arbeiten
muss eine Aufgabe die es nicht nur in
Sachsen zu lösen gilt vergleichbare
Studien kommen in anderen Bundesländern
zu ähnlichen
Zahlen vor gut einer Stunde hat der
sechstägige Streik bei der Bahn begonnen
im Güterverkehr ging es um 18 Uhr los um
2 Uhr heute Nacht will die
lockführergewerkschaft GDL ihren Streik
auf den Personenverkehr ausweiten die
Bahn hat einen Notfahrplan
veröffentlicht der Arbeitskampf soll bis
Montagabend dauern und wäre damit der
bisher längste Streik in der Geschichte
der
Bahn israel soll der islamistischen
Hamas eine Feuerpause angeboten haben
wenn im Gegenzug alle Geiseln
freigelassen werden bisher aber gehen
die heftigen Kämpfe weiter 24
israelische Soldaten sind heute bei
einem Angriff auf sie in Gaza getötet
worden es war der schwerste Verlust für
Israel seit Beginn des Krieges lü wepot
Beisetzung eines israelischen Soldaten
heute früh in Jerusalem einer von 24
gefallenen gestern im Gazastreifen der
verlustreichste Tag für die Armee seit
Monaten Regierungschef Netanyahu zeigte
sich
erschüttert gestern war einer der
schwierigsten Tage seit Kriegsbeginn wir
verneigen uns vor den Gefallenen und
werden weiter alles unternehmen um unser
Ziel zu erreichen einen vollständigen
Sieg der katarische Nachrichtenkanal
aljasira zeigte Bilder der Explosion von
Gebäuden in Gaza bei der gestern allein
21 israelische Soldaten getötet wurden
der Druck auf Israels Regierung die
Geiseln jetzt mit allen Mitteln
zurückzuholen wächst wütende Angehörige
der Verschleppten protestierten gestern
im Parlament nach Medienberichten hat
die Regierung über den Vermittler Katar
der Hamas eine mehrmatige Feuerpause
gegen die Freilassung der Geiseln
angeboten die Gefechte in Gaza gehen
unterdessen weiter und Hamas lehnt eine
Feuerpause ab sie fordert ein sofortiges
Ende der
Kämpfe wir hoffen zwar sind aber nicht
unbedingt optimistisch jedenfalls
verhandeln beide Seiten weiter so viel
können wir
sagen die Lage der Bevölkerung in Gaza
ist weiter dramatisch nach
palästinensischen Angaben sind seit
Kriegsbeginn mehr als 25000 Menschen
getötet worden es fehlt an Nahrung und
medizinischer Versorgung seit einer
Woche sind außerdem Telefon und
Internetverbindungen
unterbrochen in den USA richten sich
gerade die Augen auf den Bundesstaat New
Hampshire und die Vorwahlen dort bei den
Republikanern die einzig verbliebene
Herausforderin von Donald Trump ist
Nicki Haley sollte sie hier schlecht
abschneiden werden ihr keine Chancen
mehr ausgerechnet
Präsidentschaftskandidatin ihrer Partei
zu werden über das Duell Claudia
B im kleinen dickville notch sind um 5
Minuten nach Mitternacht die Stimmen
bereits ausgezählt alle sechs für Nicki
Haley der Kampf des Tages ist damit
eröffnet unterwegs in New Hampshire
viele Wechselwähler gibt es hier sie
können sich als unabhängige registrieren
und an der republikanischen Vorwahl
teilnehmen diese moderaten Wähler
könnten Sand ins Getriebe der Trump
wahlkampfmaschinerie
streuen Nicki hy sie ist jung sie ist
frisch das brauchen
wir Trump ist etwas grob aber in seiner
ersten Amtszeit hat er eine Menge
geschafft im Prost im ländlichen New
Hampshire begegnet uns wie überall
Unzufriedenheit mit den Kandidaten Trump
und
Biden wir haben zwei ältere Herren die
wetteifern um den gleichen Job das
stresst mich das ist als würde mein
87-jähriger Vater kandidieren wir
brauchen etwas
Neues die frühere unootschafterin greift
nach der einzigen Chance hier und heute
muss muss sie es schaffen sie greift
Trump direkt an er hinterlässt überall
Chaos wir können nicht ein Land in
Unordnung haben und eine Welt in Flammen
das würden wir nicht
überleben doch die Trump Fans feiern
schon ihr Idol führt in den Umfragen und
wenn er hier heute siegt ist Trump die
Kandidatur für die Präsidentschaft so
gut wie
sicher gleich drei deutsche können sich
in diesem Jahr Hoffnung auf einen Oscar
machen die usfilmakademie hat heute die
Nominierungen bekannt gegeben
Schauspielerin Sandra Hüller geht in der
Kategorie beste hauptdstellerin ins
Rennen für ihre Rolle in Anatomie eines
Falls als bester internationaler Film
ist das Lehrerzimmer von Ilka chatak
nominiert und Altmeister Wim Wenders
kann auch hoffen sein Film perfect days
tritt für Japan
an nennt man das Stichwort Frank
fararian fallen sofort die Titel solcher
Welthits wie Daddy Cool Mar Baker
od der B bon und mil vanil Musik Kostüme
Stimme alles war frankfarian und doch
war es nur ein Teil seines
künstlerischen Schaffens in mehr als se
Jahrzehnten der deutsche Musikproduzent
ist jetzt mit 82 Jahren in Florida
gestorben Christian Volk
erinnert es ist der Sound einer ganzen
Generation prägt hat ihn dieser Mann
Franz Reuter alias Frank Farian mehr als
800 Millionen verkaufte Platten ergilt
als der international erfolgreichste
Produzent aus Deutschland sein
Erfolgsrezept die Videos müssen
Atmosphäre haben dass die Leute sagen
boah das toucht mich und dann rennen sie
auch in die in die Plattenläden und
wollen das Lied haben und Sie hören sich
dann Hundt mal an bis es nicht mehr bis
es aus den Ohren rauskommt vor seinem
großen Durchbruch versucht sich der
ausgebildete Koch als Rock and Roll
Musiker später wird der Schlagersänger
und Rocky seine erste Nummer 1 in
Deutschland
die doch seine wahre Berufung findet er
als Produzent etwa für Bonnie
[Musik]
m war natürlich die Bestätigung für für
das viele bastel für das viele Arbeiten
und für das und für die viele viele
Wartezeiten all den Jahren 60er Jahren
70er Jahre habe ich auf den Erfolg
gewartet und es kam keiner und dann war
er
da Erfolg und einen Grammy brachte ihm
auch das Duo Milli Vanilli bis klar
wurde dass die Sänger gar nicht selbst
singen die Lieder hatte Farian schon
eingespielt bevor er die Band überhaupt
gegründet hatte mit seinen Songs war
Farian fester Bestandteil eines
Lebensgefühls was davon bleibt sind
Ohrwürmer und Hits für die
Ewigkeit und jetzt kommen wir zum
souveränen Sieg der deutschen Handballer
gestern Abend gegen ung ganz ganz starke
Antwort auf den schwachen Auftritt zu
vor gegen Österreich das dhbteam wie
verwandelt vor allem die Offensive 35 Z
28 morgen noch ein Sieg gegen die
Kroaten ja und das EM Halbfinale ist
erreicht im Herzen eines Wintermärchens
der Blick in die Kabine nach dem Sieg
gegen Ungarn Erleichterung und Freude
sind bei der Mannschaft von Alfred
geslerson mit Händen zu greifen wir
haben es jetzt wieder in der eigenen
Hand wir müssen morgen gen Kroatien
gewinnen ja ist jetzt irgendwie nur noch
ein Schritt bis zum Halbfinale und wir
haben alle mega Bock und die Stimmung
überragen die Fans in der Kölner Arena
in Ektase die Mannschaft auf der Platte
im Spielrausch das Angriffsspiel endlich
wieder variantenempo und erfolgreich das
wird es morgen auch gegen Kroatien
brauchen die sind zwas schon
ausgeschieden aber trotzdem mit Vorsicht
zu genießen wir sind gewarnt davor dass
da ganz viel Qualität kommt und die
Jungs vor alleningen nichts mehr zu
verlieren haben also jeder kann spielen
und sich zeigen ohne dass er irgendwie
Angst vor Fehlern haben muss deswegen
ich glaube das wird ein gefährliches
Spiel hoffentlich mit Happy End damit
der halbfinaltraum Wirklichkeit
wird zu den Australien Open die beiden
ersten halbfinalasten stehen fest
Jannick Sinner nach einem klaren
Dreisatzsieg gegen Andrej Rubel ja und
Titelverteidiger Novak dokovic der
serber auf dem Weg zum
Titel Gewinn in
Melbourne der US-Amerikaner Taylor Fritz
Nummer 12 der Setzliste schafft mit
einem as den Satzausgleich und bringt
den Superstar ins Schwitzen
vorübergehend aber der 36 Jahre alte
Serbe lässt sich nicht abbringen von
seinem Projekt 25 Grand Slam Sieg nach
dem Break zu Beginn des dritten Satzes
läuft alles für dokovic im vierten Satz
Match
zum den er mit einer extrem platzierten
Vorhand
abschließtokov steht im Halbfinale trotz
des Sieges sucht er noch nach seiner
Topform und bei den Frauen stehen Arina
sabenka und K im Halbfinale danke schön
groß Erfolge hat auch die NASA die
verdankt sie ihrer Milliarden Dollar
teuren Technik trotzdem wä sie fast am
Öffnen einer Art Dose gescheitert die
Nase hatte mit einer Sonde erstmals auf
dem Asteroiden Benu ein wenig
Sternenstaub eingesammelt die
geröllprobe wurde in 100.000 km Höhe
abgeworfen das Problem unten auf der
Erde kriegten die Fachleute den Behälter
einfach nicht auf nach vier Monaten
präsentierten sie endlich stolz Steine
und Staub daren Spuren von Wasser und
Kohlenstoff kommen wir noch kurz zum
Wetter morgen wird es stürmisch wann
genau und wo das erfahren Sie gleich von
Christer Orben das heute journal läuft
um 21:45 Uhr mit Christian Siebers
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend jetzt kommt das
nächste mächtige Sturmtief das bringt
uns dann endgültig einen Schwall milder
Luft und eben auch starken Wind
verbreitet gibt es morgen Sturm und
schwere sturmböhen zwischen 60 und 100
km pro Stunde an der See oder auch auf
den Bergen wie den Brocken oder dem
Feldberg im Schwarzwald sind es über 100
km pro Stunde vormittags liegt der
Schwerpunkt an der Nordsee nachmittags
an der Ostsee während dann von Südwesten
der Wind schon wieder etwas abnimmt
heute Nacht kommt der Warmfront Regen
über der Mitte weiter nach Osten voran
nach Mitternacht dann mit der Annäherung
der Kaltfront gibt's im Nordwesten die
ersten sturmböhen und der Wind nimmt
deutlich zu und dieser bringt dann auch
die milde Luft das ergibt einen
spannenden Temperaturverlauf die
Tiefstwerte der Nacht 8 bis 1° werden
nämlich alle samt heute Abend schon
erreicht im Laufe der Nacht wird's dann
immer milder bis zum Vormittag da gibt
es Werte zwischen 9 und
vorfrühlingshaften 14° am Rhein
nachmittags gehen die Temperaturen von
Norden her dann schon wieder zurück und
das liegt an der Kaltfront die
vormittags mit ihren Schauern noch über
der Mitte liegt nachmittags dann an die
Alpen zieht dann lockert in der Mitte
auch etwas auf im Nordosten gibt's den
ganzen Tag Schauer und dazu eben dieser
Sturm informieren Sie sich und achten
Sie auf herabstürzende Gegenstände am
Donnerstag beruhigt sich die Wetterlage
am Freitag kommt das nächste Tief mit
Regen und Wind und am Samstag gibt's
teilweise viel Sonne tschüss